everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're starting our
coverage of the 2017 grand prix in
geneva it's the third leg of the grand
prix tour if you're not too familiar
with how the grand prix is set up this
year there's going to be four
tournaments we've already had two Grand
Prix Geneva is the third one and the
fourth one will be at the end of the
year in November there's 24 candidates
some of the top players in the world
those competitors are going to be
playing three of the four legs of the
Grand Prix so there will be players that
are not present at this tournament that
are actually in the Grand Prix they're
just going to be playing at the other
three the top two players from the Grand
Prix at the end of the four will get
invited to the candidates tournament in
March of 2018 that's important because
the winner of that will then go on to
face Magnus Carlsen in November at the
end of 2018
Sergey kada yakin was the victorious
person in the Kandice tournament last
year and so he automatically has a bid
into the candidates tournament for next
year so you won't see him there are also
some other notable players that you
won't see in the Grand Prix series
Fabiana Caruana vision on to blob
chromatic Wesley so these are some of
the players not trying to get a seat
into the candidates tournament through
the Grand Prix series instead they'll be
looking through the the chess World Cup
which is going to be in September going
to be a really fun tournament that won
its 128 players single elimination
tournament we will be covering that one
as well but today we're going to be
getting started with the Grand Prix at
Geneva our two competitors why it's
going to be played by a nice Giri he is
currently 11th in the world and also a
raja baath playing the black pieces he's
32nd in the world but definitely a
strong competitor played in the
candidates tournament twice before I
think his earliest or latest one was
about five years ago so definitely
looking to get back in that tournament
both of these players did not play in
the first leg of the Grand Prix they did
play in the last one and they tied for
third so these tournaments are heavily
skewed towards giving points to the
person that wins the tournament so both
these players need a very very good
showing if not need a
when in this leg of the Grand Prix to
kind of give themselves a shot of being
in the top two with so many competitors
of 24 competitors every point counts so
we'll go ahead and get into it with a
nice GRE starting out with pawn to d4
and then raja baath starting with Knight
to f6 and we start to get into the
Queens gambit declined line and after
Bishop to e7 White has a few options he
decides to go with Bishop to f4 could
also see Bishop to g5 Castle on the
Kings side maybe a Knight to d7 here or
could have even decided to play the
exchange line see takes here on d5 you
could see the knight come back here
exchange we now have a semi-open file on
the C file and of the e-file so a lot of
different options as far as how GRE
wanted to continue he decided to go
ahead and play Bishop to f4 now Castle
on the kingside Jewry's going to
solidify his pawn chain once he has his
dark squared Bishop outside that pawn
chain with pawn to e3 also opening up
for his light square bishop get involved
then if you want to go and castle on the
King side nice at e7 you know he has
lots of options here he could have just
played Knight to c6 if he wanted to he
could have even pushed forward with this
pawn if he wanted to decide to go ahead
and play Knight here to d7 and then pawn
up here to c5 this is a move we don't
see all too often many times you'll
start to see an exchange right here pawn
takes on d5 the Knight takes Knight
takes all of a sudden this is completely
fine and this Knight is no longer really
supporting that night here on f6 so
white kind of has a leg up he can bring
his rook over here to c1 get his light
square Bishop involved with the game
castle on the King side very very safe
opening for white but he decides to go
and try to cramp blacks position here
with pawn here to c5 now lay it nice to
h5 attacking the bishop here on f4
decides to go ahead and ignore it with
Bishop to d3 and I really expected to
see Bishop to e5 just not giving up your
bishop early on into the game is
something we usually see a high level
play but decides to go ahead and give it
up so Bishop to a d3 Knight takes on f4
and then
recapture so white does have a double
pawn structure here on the F file and
then pawn to c6 so kind of getting into
a semi slob a variation for black he
could have tried to open things up with
pawn to d6 starting to force an exchange
get his Bishop here to be seven trying
to control these light squares but
instead decides okay I'm going to be
patient I'm going to play pawn here to
c6 semi slot very known for solid
defense and having a good pawn structure
getting into the in game and it kind of
looks at the board and said why it's not
doing a whole lot here and I have a
better pawn structure than my opponent
let's go ahead and play pawn here to c6
will have to be aware of his
LightSquared bishop sometimes in this
opening if you don't have it outside the
pawn chain before you kind of close it
off it is sometimes difficult to get
that Bishop involved into the game so
he's going to be looking to do that
Queen here to see to adding protection
with the bishop on d3 eyeing down on
this square on h7 so we have Roger Bob
to go ahead and played pawn to h6 just
ignoring that threat right away or not
necessarily ignoring it but making sure
that he does not fall for that attack
castle on the King side a queen is t7
just consuming hid develop myth also
attacking the pawn here on f4 and this
nice here on e5 there's a couple things
one it kind of forces his opponent at
some point to allow white to no longer
have double pawns it also does stop the
Queen from attacking the pawn here on f4
since he doesn't really want to be
playing things like pawn to g3 so we do
have our three Bob decides to go ahead
and exchange on board so after the
Knight takes on e5 the pawn recaptures
right here so we start to take a look on
board white does have a backwards pawn
here on d4 so black can start to if he
can get behind enemy lines and start to
attack this Square this is a weakness
for white on the other hand black has a
double bishop pair but it's not an open
board state you usually want bishops
where there's not a lot going on the
turn of the board right now there's no
positive even come off the board so
black is going to be looking to break up
the center really allow him sell
to utilize the bishops were from
Whiteside aboard and these Jewry is
looking to have the most powerful minor
piece with the night and really try to
maneuver around the board and put
himself in some really good outpost
moves
I'm really trying to control continue to
keep his opponent cramped on board a
black one to make sure he's not cramped
Bishop to d7 finishing his development
also allowing for the rooks to kind of
connect right here now we start to see
pawn pushing forward on the Queen type
it's not much else that I can do right
here it is kind of blocked in the center
of the board
pawn to b6 so it's trying to break
things up a little bit pawn before we do
see an exchange an imp on to f6 and this
is kind of one of those where usually
you will see the rook immediately come
here to b8 trying to control this open
file right here but black looks at and
says there may be a better option I need
to start opening up this board state and
so f6 is really the only option that he
has now white does have a pretty solid
move because you can just counter back
with pawn to f4 if there is an exchange
on here that's going to be fine
so black decides not to go ahead and
take right there now he decides to go
and play rook to b8 but first wanted to
go and play that pawn to f6 now jewry
solidifies his pawn turn on the King
side with pawn to g3 then Queen to a5
starting to try to have an aggressive
attack on at the Queen side the board he
does have control of the B file so we
can start to put pressure on this Queen
side of the board now the knight comes
back here to e tube does not want to
have to worry about all of its pieces
particularly as Queen right now just
defending the square here on c3 so
brings his knight back here to e2 but
this is also pretty good Square for
black if he looks at it this minor piece
can be very very scary on a board that's
kind of locked up because it can kind of
move around have some nice outpost if
it's back here on the second rank that's
exactly where Raja Bob would like to see
it because it's no longer threatening
him he's gonna have to have a few moves
because you can't really move it right
now before he asked to even worry about
it
Bishop back here to e8 and then the
bishop up here too
g6o black looking to get his lights or a
bishop involved into the game decides
not bring it over here to see eight and
then a six and said decides to go ahead
and bring it here to e8 and then over
here to maybe G six depending on where's
apone ISM more than likely here to h5
and start to attack this night on e 2
and Y kind of looks at and says I'll go
ahead and exchange material if you want
to which I think is you know fine for
for both sides I think since black is a
little bit cramped I would prefer to
hold on to as much material as wife but
we do have an issue we decide to go
ahead and exchange and then clean up
here to g6 and then Queen down here to
d2 and this is why I like it a little
bit more for black it's starting to put
more pressure on his opponent this queen
is now attacking this backward pawn as
we talked about on d4 it's attacking the
knight here on e 2 and we're kind of
forced to see this rook here to f2 but
now even more white pieces are just
holding down the fort and black just
finds an incremental better move with
queen up here to e3 still attacking all
the same critical squares here on d4 and
a knight but it's also now pinning down
at this rook to the king so white is
good and material has a good pawn
structure but all in all black with this
one piece here on III is starting to
really dictate the play and what white
can do because so much of his material
it's kind of just blocked over here and
then black could eventually bring his
rooks over to at this B file and start
to put even more pressure on his
opponent now whites in a tricky spot he
was back at c2 but he can't really play
that anymore because after pawn takes on
e5 then he's in a tough spot he can't
take with his F pawn because they need
to see Queen takes on f2 check that's
going to be extremely bad he can't take
with his deep on because then just
Bishop takes on c5 that's threatening
the Queen down here to f2 that's also
going to be bad and if you try something
else maybe rook over here to d1 well
then we just see pawn to e4 just putting
more and more pressure on his opponent
this could definitely get a little bit
tricky you could see King to g2 but then
the Queen is going to take over here on
a3 start to gobble up material then he
has a passed pawn on the a file that he
can start to push what with white really
has to worry about his King side of the
board it been said he were to play
something like Queen to c1 trying to
stop the Queen from coming over here
then we talked about this earlier but
now the divorce is going to come over
here to b3 attacking this pawn next move
if he wants to recover here to b8 just
putting more and more pressure on his
opponent so at the end of all this we
see that it's it's not going to be that
good if he brings his Queen back here to
see to so he finds a little bit better
move and that is Queen to g4 but it's
not it's still not that great but it
does pressure this square here on e6
which is undefended Black has two
options he can play h7 he can play f7 I
really like f7 just because it protects
the Pawnee on it isa 'kz he decides to
go ahead and play King to h7 but he is
the he's the Grandmaster in all of this
so we'll go ahead and heed to his play
here Queen takes on e6 and then we're
over here to East 8th looking for
discovered attack so after the bishop
moved then going to be attacking this
Queen here on e6 pawn up here to eat a4
and this is kind of one of those where
you almost feel like white forgets what
the game is about the game is not about
this pawn over here on a3 if this was a
passed pawn you know maybe we could sit
here and say maybe he has enough moves
to do that but that's not what the game
is about he has a lot of different
options besides a4 he could play Queen
to f5 and then you could see pawn to g6
Queen e6 you could see the pawn capture
Queen capture if you wanted to that's
one option it could have also played
just Queen takes on c6 start to gobble
up material now pawn takes on e5 do the
Queen take on d5 pawn capture on d4 just
a lot of exchanges on board both sides
really trying to gain control of the
center of the board this is a pretty
even game right here I think white is
finding this
if he could go ahead and get one of
these pawn chains off the board his
minor piece is going to extremely well
with just one side of the board with
pawn structures but he's had to go and
play pawn to a forward not really
threatening his opponent and definitely
not advancing any of his initiatives
that he has on board so black says okay
I'm going to continue with my game plan
pawn takes on e5 and then the Queen
takes on e5 Queen over here to d3 like
has a really good attack does not want
to exchange his Queens off the board
right now Queen over here to h4 we could
see this bishop start to attack if you
wanted to pawn or excuse me Bishop here
to f6 so that's exactly what he does
this backward pawns right here tonight
on e 2 is protecting this but he brings
his Bishop right here to attack it rook
over here to f1 this is where you know
it's really interesting to see these
top-level pros play because it's very
very easy to just play Bishop takes on
d4 and I'm not even sure this is a
terrible move at all it it's pinned down
this rook here on f2 it gobbles up more
material you can even later on take here
on c5 start to push his pawn that more
pressure he could probably have a pretty
good endgame with this but he sees a
slightly better option he plays pawn to
g6 trying to put his opponent in a worse
position Queen here to g4 pawn h5
picking the Queen the Queen comes here
to d7 this is a very aggressive square
for the Queen but also it's completely
away from the action the action is kind
of going on on the King side of the
board for wife all the speeds are just
playing defense right now the Queen up
here in d7 if he doesn't have the
strongest of attacks he's not really
helping his team right now that's kind
of what we see look here to e7 and then
Queen to d6 not helping at all King to
g7 in the knight here to c1 and this is
where things start to get a little bit
tricky for whites because yes he is
getting his knights into a square
hopefully where he can start to do
something but to do that he has to bring
it back to the first ring that's not
where he wants to be his opponent can
easily just bring his Queen back here
and then all of a sudden he has a minor
piece
it's not helping at all if you kind of
analyze this position more and more
black definitely has a much stronger
attack in black black is going to be
sitting there attacking White's going to
be sitting there trying to figure out
what he's going to be doing
ruk over here to d1 starting to attack
or defend at the square here on a d4
rook to e8 so blacks utilizing just a
concept of controlling the open file
which is a foul central square makes a
lot of sense and then white decides now
and only now to start to gobble up
material so Queen takes on c6 I do think
it's a little bit late a rook down here
at the e1 after rook to f1 we see a nice
little decoy with Bishop takes on d4 and
this is a decoy because after the rook
takes then the rook takes on f1 after
the King takes in the Queen can come
down here to h3 and this is kind of
going to be all she wrote
King to f2 Queen takes on h2 gobbling
out material and after the check the
rooks going to come down here to e1 and
this is going to be game over from here
Antony she resigns so great game by rush
of off being able to find a win after an
opening where he just played defensive
waited for his opponent to kind of make
a mistake played solid throughout the
game neither player really put
themselves in a terrible terrible
position neither side really tried to go
any crazy lines tactics where you had to
analyze and say wow there's these three
crazy positions that both sides could go
down it was kind of straightforward but
at the end of it small little variance
in some of the moves that black played
that white kind of chose that suboptimal
lines and at the end of the day a black
got the victory sometimes people will
say how could this game continue from
here you know there's you do see the
checkmate here with Queen to f1 there's
no really way for white to stop if he
comes up here to Queen to d7 trying to
you know a perpetual check King to h6 is
going to stop that right away there's no
real good way for white to continue to
check his opponent he could just
continue to give away material if you
wanted to but
the end of this it's going to be pretty
futile he will end up losing so he
decides to go ahead and just resign so
that is round one thank you everyone for
watching we will have coverage of every
round so thank you for watching and I'll
see you tomorrow
for round number two